i think it's truly a special honour for
any of us who hold elected office to be
representing the communities from which
we all come
i think that we carry the hopes and the
expectations of workers of families and
businesses that are relying on us to
work together in a spurt of cooperation
and to deliver real change
the public will be rightly watching on
today as they juggle their work and
family responsibilities and they're
struggling to manage their household
budgets and they're watching on in the
hope that the parties in this chamber
have the maturity and the courage to
shoulder our responsibilities and to get
down to business and act in the common
good
there is absolutely no reason why we
should be in a rolling crisis even for
one second
over the past two years this assembly
and this executive has delivered and we
have proved the politics and power
sharing here can work when we give
leadership deliver good public services
and champion difference and inclusion
but oppose division these are my values
also
the democratic outcome of this election
must now be respected
today i stand ready we stand ready to
elect a speaker form an executive and
take on the leadership of the northern
ireland executive as a first minister
for all and a government that works for
all of the people
it is the job of our heroic doctors
nurses and nhs staff to treat and care
for patients but it is our job as
politicians to properly fund that
service it is time to agree a three-year
budget and immediately invest an extra 1
million pounds in our health service
workers and families are facing really
hard times because of the cost of living
crisis and that demands our immediate
action not protest
mr speaker this is our our of decision
not tomorrow and not for a moment longer
can the day you pay deny democracy
punish the public and boycott this
assembly and executive and prevent us
from putting money into people's pockets
every party in this chamber told the
electorate that they would turn up on
day one
will the dup have failed on day one
the people and the businesses here want
to have confidence and they want to have
hope for the future
so let's take now time to look forwards
not backwards
we and shinfam will continue to turn up
to work in partnership with willing
partners to deliver for people today and
every day
finally mr speaker let me
say a few words just to yourself in
terms of your last sitting at the
assembly
um let me take this opportunity to thank
you and for the civility and the
exercise of restraint that you've
encouraged us all to write your tenure
in your role as speaker helping to
moderate better community relations
inside but also importantly outside of
our wider community
your four decades of dedicated public
service leave a legacy for which many
politicians would rightly be proud and
we thank you for that and may also
acknowledge your good wife liz also in
the gallery today because as we all know
when you're an elected life it can be
very very challenging and we all need
our family support and we very much
recognize that so thank you for
everything that you've done
i called paul gibbon
thank you mr speaker and uh can i too uh
thank you for your work as speaker of
this assembly and not only
with the 90 members guiding people but
also when it came to private members
bill of which i had won and your advice
during that period of time and wish you
well the class of 98
now reduces to i think only three
members who are in this chamber today
that were there back all those years ago
mr speaker in october 2019 at a time
when sinn fein held northern ireland to
ransom for three years in refusing to
form a
government this assembly sought to elect
a speaker
and the leader of the sdlp then column
eastwood said and i quote we will not be
able to have an executive northern
ireland assembly or north south
ministerial council it is our clear view
it is the good friday agreements clear
view that the best way to affect any
change to any legislation is to do it
within the confines of those structures
and that it will not happen as part of a
shadow assembly at all
but will lead only to the fundamental
destruction of the good friday agreement
the irish sea border has fundamentally
undermined the belfast agreement
it has changed our relationship
with the united kingdom and not one
unionist elected to this assembly
supports the northern ireland protocol
we do not consent
that is a fundamental cornerstone of the
belfast agreement the principle of
consent
and that is gone as a result of the
northern ireland protocol
last september
we outlined the problems we gave forward
our solutions
we were patient
we have been reasonable
we allowed space for the united kingdom
and the european union to engage in
negotiations and talks and so the talks
went on and on as we continued to be
patient
now whilst others in this place acted in
a divisive manner and called for its
rigorous implementation
at a time when we have a cost of living
crisis members of this house want to
drive up the cost of transportation they
want to harm people as a result of the
northern ireland protocol
we don't
and we put forward pragmatic solutions
the democratic unionist party received a
mandate
in the assembly elections a mandate
to remove the rsc border and our mandate
will be given respect
we've engaged with the prime minister
this week the foreign secretary the
secretary of state and our message is
now clear
it is time for action
words will no longer suffice
and it's because we believe in
devolution and it's because we want the
sustainability of these institutions
to endure that we are taking the action
that we are taking today